Ahzubillahi mina Shaytana Raheem Bismillaha Rahmanu Raheem Alhamdulillahi Saneh Al-Khalti Al-Aqmali Nizam Wa Ahsani Kawam Al-Wadi Al-Shia Ifi Ajdari Maqam Wa Arthaqi Masam Alhamdulillahi Ladi La Tan Qusu Qazaa Inuhu Wa La Yubidu Mulkuhu Wa La Tarahul Ayoon Wa Taazub Anhu Aharakatun Wa La Sukoon
Walam tazal walaatu zalu abadah Was salatu was salamu alal mu'ayyad ablagil kalam Muhammadin al-Mabroos sallallahu alaihi wa 'ala alaihi wa salam lihidayatikaaf fati anaam ila subul salam wa ila madalla ali wala yam Alhamdulillah al-lazilam yattakhiz waladan walam yakun lahu shalikun salmulk walam yakun lahu waliyum minazulay wa kabbir hu talbirah
Alhamdulillah, aladhi anzala ala abdihil kitab, walam yaja Allahu aywaja.
Alhamdulillah, aladhi nahmaduhu, wa nasta ainuhu, wa nasta ghafiruhu, wa nu'minubihi, wa na tawakkalu alai.
Wa na'udubillahi min shuroori anfusina, wa min sayyi'ati aamalina.
Man yahdihillahu fala mudillala, wa man yudlilhu fala haadiyala.
Wa nashadu an laa ilaha illallah wahdahula sharikala Wa nashadu anna Muhammadan Abdullahi wa rasulih Arsalahullahu ta'ala bilhuda wadin al-haq liyuzhirahu aladinikulli wa kafabillahi shaheeda Wa nashadu anna maulana ali ibnabi qalib wasi yuhu wa ziru fa salallahu alayhim wa ala alayhim wa sallimahum tasliman kathiran kathira
Allahum mala ilmalana ila ma al-damtana inna ka'antar alimul Hakeem Allahum ma alimna bima yanfa'ana wa yanfa'ana bima al-damtana Allahum ma inna na'udubika min ail min la yanfar wa min qalbin la yaksha wa min aainin la tadba wa min nafsin la tashfar Allahum ma atina nufusina takwaha wa zakkana fa anta khairum mina zakkaha
Anta waliyuna wa mawlana wanayamal mawla wanayaman nasir wala khawla wala qwatailah billah alil azim.
Fa'amma ba'adi akulo subhanahum wa ta'ala thikitabhil kareem ba'adanakula azubillahim mina shaytana rajim bismillah rahmanu rahim.
Rabbish rahli sadri wa yaserli amri wahlolu qdatam millisani yaf kahu kawli.
Allahum masabitna indal maawtibila ilaha illa Allahum wa Allahum majal namin aladina amanu wa amil salihat wa tawasaubil haq wa tawasaubil sabr amin ya rabbil alameen once again assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu in the last couple of sessions we learned about the Rahma of Allah .
I hope I was able to provide a clear understanding of what that word Rahma means and what it represents.
Just to quickly reiterate, the word Rahma is a combination of unconditional love, constant care, genuine concern, and an unlimited supply of mercy and compassion.
And the two frequently used derivatives of Rahma are Ar-Rahman and Ar-Rahim, right?
And the attribute Ar-Rahman highlights the intensity, the urgency,
promptness but also the interim and the temporary state of that Rahma whereas the attribute Ar-Rahim it highlights the long-term and permanent qualities of his Rahma we then studied the root word of Rahma itself in the last session which comes from Raham and it literally means the womb of a mother we saw some
you know magnificent examples that the womb provides in order to depict and demonstrate the Rahma of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala you know we saw we drew some parallels to understand the role that the womb plays in development of the fetus and the role that Allah plays in the development of a human being and we like for example we know that how the womb takes a shapeless drop of liquid
and by its Rahma it transforms it into a living child and so we can draw the analogy that you know it is the Rahma of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that shapes and transforms our spiritual existence our spiritual being the same way right his Rahma takes human beings in their raw and ignorant form a form that really has no goal no purpose outside the confines of this dunya
and then he transforms them into these incredible personalities that you know we we do not even mention their names without adding Rahmatullah Alai or Radi Allah Anhu right and and this is why Rasulullah is called Rahmatullah Alameen that's one of his titles Rahmatullah Alameen he is called Rahma for the entire world because he took on the role of a mother's womb in shaping and nurturing the spiritual existence of humanity
Not just for the people of his time, not just for the Sahaba, the companions, but for all of humanity till the end of time.
We know how a mother suffers in order to provide comfort to her child.
You know, how she protects them, how she protects it, nurtures it, feeds it, how she goes through various hardships, pain and suffering in order to transform that shapeless mass into that living, breathing child.
So in the same way Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala through his various Intermediaries, you know his Imams his prophets his messengers he shapes our spiritual existence in the same way And historically just like the pregnant mother historically we see that you know these people suffered various hardships as well to deliver the message of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to their nations in order to you know in strive and
change the human condition just as a mother suffers and endures pain for the development of her child in the same way these prophets and messengers they've suffered at the hands of humanity for their own benefit just as the fetus becomes the reason for their hardship nations become a source of hardship for these messengers but they endure all of it for their development so there's a perfect analogy between the two
So today I want to talk about some of the manifestations of this Rahma and hopefully share a different perspective with you.
Because one of the most amazing qualities of the womb, the Raham, is that it expands.
Right?
The womb expands to accommodate the needs of the fetus.
And that provides us with a beautiful reminder of the fact
that Allah's Rahma expands to fulfill not only the needs of His creation, but also to forgive their shortcomings, to forgive their sins and transgressions.
His immense forgiveness for us is one of the manifestations of His infinite compassion towards His creation.
Because Allah knows that we are people of extremely weak character.
We are people who are enslaved by our worldly desires, our passions, our caprice.
He knows that, but then He also knows that we are trying our best in our efforts to move towards Him.
We're all trying, doing whatever we can
to move towards him whether it's you know centimeter by centimeter or inch by inch in whatever way we can we are making an effort somehow however small it is you know we are trying to move towards him so he compensates for that weakness and he and he strengthens our shortcomings through his forgiveness so there's a beautiful verse in the Quran that I want to share with you
It says um...
Qul ya ibadi, Alladina Asrafu ala anfusihim laa taqnatum min Rahmatillah.
In Allaha yaqfiru zunu ba jami'a innahuhu wal ghafoorwahim.
So, he says Qul ya ibadi, Alladi Asrafu ala anfusihim.
O my slaves who have transgressed against themselves by their sins.
Now, what slaves is he talking about?
Right?
The word abd, now you should all know what that means, right?
He's not talking to the disbelievers or the polytheists or the idol worshippers.
No, he's talking to us, those who have submitted, who have developed a certain awareness of their master and they have willingly submitted themselves to his little bubiya.
That's an abd, right?
So he's talking to these
to these slaves.
He's talking to us Muslims, as believers, right?
Ya Ibadi.
Now, linguistically this form of calling someone implies an extreme closeness.
Ya Ibadi, this form of addressing someone implies an extreme form of closeness and it implies extreme love, extreme intimacy.
Right?
So, Ya ibadi implies a deep connection or an intense love in that statement.
If it was just a casual call, like a master calling their servants, he would have said, Ya ayuhal ibad.
And that would have meant just like all slaves.
But there would be no intimacy or love in that statement.
But in this verse he says, Ya ibadi.
which represents an extreme closeness.
Oh my beloved slaves, my revered slaves, my cherished slaves.
You see?
You understand the difference?
So there's a deep intimacy in that call.
And what type of slaves is he addressing?
Faithful slaves?
You know, trustworthy slaves, obedient slaves, exemplary slaves?
No.
the ones who have crossed all limits and all boundaries of transgressions against themselves the one who have caused severe harm to their souls by living a life of sin by living a life of hopelessness by living a life of disobedience to Allah
by living a lifestyle that is harmful and detrimental to their spiritual progression.
These are the type of slaves he is addressing, but there is something so beautiful that the scholars point out about this verse, which is again the use of the word ya ibadi that precedes this statement.
Allah is still calling them my slaves, you see.
Allah is still saying that no matter who you are and no matter what you've done, you are still My slaves.
So you can see that there is absolutely no abandonment on the part of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Just as the womb does not abandon its fetus if it's deformed or you know.
Allah constantly maintains that relationship of Rahma with us, even though we may be the worst of the worst.
We may be the most sinful people on the face of this earth who are constantly walking on very thin ice, but Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala He still maintains that relationship and that connection with us through the use of the word ya ibaadi my slaves, my beloved slaves, right?
SubhanAllah.
Allahu.
The ones who have done severe harm to their souls and to themselves.
never ever lose hope in the mercy of Allah not even the slightest bit I mean I won't get going I mean there's a lot of technical details here I won't go into them but just just want to talk about the use of this word la at the beginning here the word la here right at the beginning it indicates unconditional absolutism
you know unconditional absoluteness like without the shred of a doubt you know how we have la ilaha illallah that also begins with la because that's what it indicates right it has that absolute finality in that statement that there is absolutely no God except Allah
Right?
That's when La is used at the beginning of a statement.
So, Allah is saying that La taqnatum mina rahmatullah.
Under no circumstances, with complete certainty, I'm making it haram on you.
I'm making it impermissible.
I'm forbidding you to lose hope in the mercy of Allah.
Ever.
Why?
And this is something amazing about the Quran that Allah never just tells us something and then not give us a reason to believe in it.
So why should we not lose hope in the mercy of Allah?
Because Allah is capable of forgiving all your sins and transgressions.
How is that possible?
I have spent an entire lifetime in his disobedience.
How is it possible for Him to forgive all my sins?
Because indeed, without the shred of a doubt, He and only He, most definitely, He is Al Ghafoor, the constantly forgiving.
This word Al Ghafoor, it follows the same phonetic pattern as Raheem.
so he's not just forgiving he's constantly forgiving he's constantly merciful that's why both both are used at the same time Al Ghafoor and Al Rahim constantly forgiving constantly merciful nothing is beyond his capacity and there is nothing that is out of his reach Allah can and will forgive all your sins so the word Al Ghafoor is so amazing it really gets to the essence of this concept of forgiveness
in the Quran when Allah talks about his ability to forgive he uses three different attributes for himself in terms of forgiveness and they all come from the same root word Ghafara okay the word Ghafara it literally means to cover something up to put a cover on something the Arabic word for helmet in you know
the word for helmet in Arabic is mikhfar comes from the same root when you put a helmet on your head can somebody see your head no it's covered right it's hidden so makfira means to forgive or to cover up the sins so that it is completely out of sight nobody can see it like it never existed now like I said there are three different forms that Allah uses in the Quran to
um to highlight basically his um which which are all derivatives of this word Ghafarah the first is Ghafir Allah calls himself Ghafir Zanb right there is a Surah actually uh called Ghafir in that he says Tanzilul kitab min Allahil Aziz al-Aleem Ghafir Zanbi waqabil taubish Sharidi al-Aqab
So linguistically the word Ghafir means the one who immediately forgives.
Someone who does not hesitate in forgiving.
Who does not have to think about, you know, let me think about it, if I give me some time I'll forgive you.
No.
A Ghafir is someone who will instantly forgive without any kind of hesitation.
He does not have to think about it before he forgives.
That's a Ghafir, right?
The second variation that he uses in the Quran is Ghafar.
Ask forgiveness of your master, indeed he is a perpetual forgiver.
So Ghafar is the one who forgives abundantly.
Ghafir was the one who forgives
Instantly Rafar is the one who forgives abundantly.
The one who has no limitations in terms of what he is going to forgive and what he's not going to forgive.
The one who can continue to forgive regardless of how much sin exists or what variation or what type of sin it is.
You know how we say you know I will forgive everything but I can never forgive betrayal.
or I can never forgive lies or I can never forgive rudeness we all have certain things that we consider unforgivable right okay I'm going to forgive all of these things but there are these things that I will not forgive there is right but Allah is a Ghaffar is someone who has no limitations in what he can and cannot forgive he can forgive everything if one truly repents that's a Ghaffar the third variation is Ghafoor
which as I said is on the same synetic pattern of Raheem and this is the highest and the most intense form of his forgiveness because it is somebody who's constantly or permanently forgiving you know even if even a Ghaffar who is even if I am let's say a Ghaffar and I'm able to forgive everything how
how many times will you do the same thing before I say you know what enough is enough now I've forgiven you 10 times 20 times 50 times 100 times that's it now I'm not gonna forgive you right so even a Hafar with his ability to forgive everything could have a limitation in terms of he could have a number but Allah is not just Rafir he's not just Rafar he's also Rafur which means linguistically that he is permanently forgiving
right so you have ***** you have Ghaffar and then you have Ghaffur and Ghaffur is the one again it's on the same phonetic pattern of Raheem which means constantly or permanently forgiving and this is the form that we are talking about in this verse Allah says Indeed he is constantly forgiving and constantly merciful so some scholars say that Ghaffur is kind of
a combination of all the other forms as well because you can be some they could be somebody who is instantly forgiving somebody who's abundantly forgiving but then what how do you deal with a creature that constantly makes mistakes that constantly transgress who is insan who forgets who constantly needs reminders who constantly slips and falls how do you deal with such a person because in that situation both the Ghafir and Ghaffar fall short
So that's why it is complemented with this final form which is ghafoor which is constant.
So no matter how many times, what type, everything about forgiveness is covered between these three forms.
SubhanAllah.
So unflinching loyalty, provision of infinite hope, a never-ending permanent relationship,
An intense, immediate, abundant forgiveness.
All of these things are essential manifestations of his Rahma.
So forgiveness is one of the beautiful manifestations of his Rahma.
Another manifestation of that expansion or that Rahma, it manifests in the form of his infinite rewards for trivial acts.
You know how we have these holy nights in which Allah offers like a ridiculous amount of reward?
So some Washif is coming in Shaban, right?
14 Shaban and I think it's like what?
20 Hajj?
Right?
What is the amount of...
people have done Hajj in this group, right?
What kind of effort does it take to do a Hajj?
Those of us who've done Hajj, we know that, right?
It's like...
it kills you, it drains you completely by the time you know everybody falls sick everybody in that sickness they have to do all of these Arkan by the time you come home you need like a one month vacation right so Hajj is an extremely physically tiring act and it has an immense reward for it but then there are nights in these in which Allah just offers 20
times that reward for a single amount.
How much effort does a thumb washer take compared to
a Hajj.
Nothing! There's no comparison yet you get the...
if you do it with the right intention you get it...
you get a reward of 20 Hajj.
So today I want to share with you a perspective of why Allah offers such rewards and hopefully you'll get a real appreciation for the intention behind these rewards and to explain that I want to you know narrate a story with you.
the you know the holy month of Ramadan is around the corner right and we know that it is the Sunnah of Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wa sallam to do a tikaf in this month and what is a tikaf it is the act of retiring oneself to the Masjid for a short period of time exclusively for the remembrance of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in silence in India Pakistan people spend like at least three days I think
the the the those um four bashikhs that we have I think up till alatul Qadr they they spend those nights and and days in itaka in which they constantly pray and they recite Quran they do tazbi or they reflect on their lives whatever it is just retiring for the sake of Allah ta'ala and Allah loves that right and for that Allah offers a huge reward Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wa sallam he stated in a hadith that the reward of itaka he says um
...............
So, whoever stays in the state of Itaqah for one single day, just one day and one night, Allah will distance him from the Hellfire by three trenches.
and each trench will be the distance between east and west.
SubhanAllah.
That's for spending one day in the Masjid in the state of Zikr.
What is that reward again?
he will be distanced from the Hellfire by three trenches and the length of each trench will be the distance between East and West.
That illustrates how beloved this act of 'Itakaaf is to Allah , right?
So just keep that reward in mind.
So one day during the month of Ramadan, Ibn Abbas who was the cousin of the Prophet, he enters a Masjid with the intention of spending a day in 'Itakaaf.
right, in order to earn that immense reward that Allah has promised.
Soon after he begins his itaqaf, he sees a Muslim brother in the Masjid looking very sad.
So he walks up to him and he inquires about his sadness.
And the man says, O cousin of the Prophet , I owe a financial debt to someone that I need to pay back but I am not able to pay it because I don't have any money.
and the weight of that debt that obligation is crushing my soul people in those days were different than us you know how we get burdened by the financial obligation that oh my god I gotta pay mortgage every month I gotta pay the bills every month and everything we look at the money they looked at the obligation itself the fact that I owe this man money that is how you know it was very different perspective in those days so Ibn Abbad says to this man
Would you like me to go to your lender and talk to him on your behalf?
Maybe I can convince him to forgive your debt or at least reduce it or maybe extend the timeline.
So, would you like me to do that?
The man says, Of course, Ya Ibn Abbas.
I'd be delighted if you did that.
So, Ibn Abbas immediately gets up, walks out of the Masjid and begins putting up his slippers.
Now, what happens when if you're in a state of Itaqaf and you step outside the Masjid, what happens?
Your 'Itakaf is broken, right?
So suddenly this man, he realizes and he says, Oh my God, Ibn Abbas was here for his 'Itakaf.
Now he's breaking his 'Itakaf for me.
Oh my God, what have I done?
He came to the Masjid for an act of worship and I am now the reason for him to break his 'Itakaf.
That is the last thing I wanted.
So he gets up and he rushes towards him and he says, Ya Ibn Abbas,
Don't you realize what you've done?
Don't you remember what you were here for?
You've just broken your itakaf.
So Ibn Abbas, he looks at this man and the Hadith narrates that tears begin to roll down from his eyes.
And this is something I find really interesting because anyone who if you look at if you study Hadith, right?
anyone who narrates the hadith this is something that you will see like after the death of the Prophet if any hadith is narrated after that you'll always see that tears begin to roll down their eyes because that was the connection they had with the Prophet right the second they would remember him they would cry so he says with tears rolling down from his eyes he says I remember my Prophet telling me
that if one of you was to strive for the need of his Muslim brother, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala rewards him with the blessings of 10 years of itakaf.
Subhanallah.
10 years of itakaf, not one day, not one month, not one year, 10 years of itakaf.
What did I just tell you?
What was the reward of one single day of Etakaf?
A distancing from Hellfire by three trenches, each trench having a length of the distance between the East and West.
That's the reward for one day of Etakaf.
Are we able to do that?
Can we do a week of Etakaf?
Seven days?
When was the last time we did a week of Etakaf?
We can't.
No one day is challenging enough.
And what's the reward for striving for the needs of a Muslim brother?
Ten years of Itaqaf.
SubhanAllah.
Now when you hear this Hadith, after hearing this Hadith, what do you naturally think of?
Right from now that I've shared this reward with you, what do you think?
You'll be like, Oh my God, I should never miss an opportunity to help anyone.
Right?
This is such a great opportunity to gain the closeness of Allah, which is true.
Sometimes the fastest way to Allah's blessing is creation itself.
No doubt about that, right?
Other people doing good to them.
So generally when people hear this hadith, they rush to help others.
When they find out that somebody is in need, they will do whatever they can to help that person out.
They keep their ears open for an opportunity to help someone.
and that is an extremely beautiful thing but what I want to point out today is something much higher and much deeper in this Hadith I want to switch your perspective and focus it on the intention of Allah and the and his Rahma this Hadith is actually amazing and I'll explain why and and and I'll give you an example so that you can understand that so let's say
I walk into a room, all of you are there, and I see that one of you in this room is very sad, okay?
Let's say my niece Maryam is very sad, right?
I find out that for some reason Mimi is looking really sad today.
So I say, look, I'll give $10 million, $10 million to anyone who makes her smile.
I'll give 10 million dollars to the one who makes Mimi smile.
Now what do you think is going to happen?
10 million bucks?
Everyone in the room is going to try to make her smile, right?
Everyone is going to flock around her throwing their best jokes at her to try to make her smile.
That's what would happen.
Now
most people will look at that gesture will look at my gesture and say oh you're so rich I mean you must have loads of money that you're willing to give 10 million dollars just to make her smile you're just throwing away 10 million dollars for a smile but then there are a very few who will get to the essence of that gesture and say wow you must love her so much
You must love her so much that her one smile is worth 10 million dollars to you.
She must mean the world to you.
You see the difference?
Because that is the reality.
The reality is that I love her so much that I'm willing to pay 10 million dollars to the one who makes her smile.
So when Allah says I'll give the reward of 10 years of itakaaf to the one who fulfills Asif's needs, even though the general understanding of that hadith becomes a motivation to do it for that reward, what most people fail to see is that how much Allah loves me.
Ya Allah, You love me so much that You'd give that much reward to anyone who fulfills my needs and removes my constrictions for me.
SubhanAllah.
You see that?
So another beautiful way to interpret this hadith and the true the true interpretation of this hadith is O you who is feeling low.
Oh you who is feeling depressed Oh you who is feeling burdened and constricted because of your troubles It is you I am looking at It is you I am focused on It is you I am concerned about It is you that I am opening doors Because I want to see you happy Because I love you
and for your happiness I will reward anyone with this amount of ridiculous Sawaab if he strives to bring you ease.
This is the Rahma of Allah that He has for each and every one of us.
Allahu Akbar.
And this transforms my perspective entirely when I see another person in need.
Because now I see this person as the one Allah loves.
So much that he's willing to reward me with such a generous amount of blessing just to help him out.
It's no longer about me and my reward, it's about his ease.
So then how beloved would I become in Allah's eyes for helping him out?
Let's say you love a person.
If somebody finally does make Mimi smile and it makes her happy, reward or no reward, that person will become closer to my heart because I love Mimi.
If someone did something really nice for a person that you love, how would that make you feel about that person?
He would come closer to your heart, isn't it?
So after understanding this perspective that closeness towards Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is what motivates me now to help another person and not so much the reward itself.
Because now I see that reward as a gesture for the one in suffering.
So I hope you really begin to appreciate the reason for these immense rewards for the most simple acts.
Right?
It is the love He has for us that He's willing to shower us with blessings for the most trivial acts of kindness.
You know, He'll give us the reward of 10-20 Hajj for a couple of hours of worship, not because of the worship, but for the love of the fact that we are taking the time out to stand before Him in remembering Him.
You see, it's not the Rukku Sojub that he cares about.
It's that love.
So I hope this
this example and and you know this hadith and this narration of Ibn Abbas it transforms our perspective in in our future worships and things like that because we just do not really see the love behind the reward we just look at the reward and we sometimes do it for that or we just you know so so that's another example of Allah's immense rahma
And another one is his response and afflictions and I'll give you another example.
Some of you might know this hadith of Rasulullah in which he tells us that when you visit a sick person, ask him to pray for you and your forgiveness.
Rasulullah says that when you visit a sick person
Ask that sick person to pray for you and your forgiveness.
Now if you think about it that sounds completely backwards doesn't it?
I mean shouldn't you be the one praying for that sick person?
He's the one in need so we should be praying that may Allah grant him help because he seems to be in need of my prayers but the hadith says ask him to pray for you and your forgiveness.
What is that about?
Let me give you an example to make this more relatable to you.
Alright?
I'll use the example of my daughter, but, you know, there are many parents in this group, we can all substitute, right?
So imagine my daughter falls very ill...
God forbid.
May Allah protect all our children from all kinds of trials and hardships.
But just as an example to explain this better, to help you understand this concept, let's say my daughter falls very sick and she is admitted in the ER.
The doctors come and tell me that she is in a lot of pain.
She's not being able to breathe properly.
Now as a father, I can't even imagine what state I would be in if that ever happened.
There is nothing more painful for a parent than to see her own child suffer, whether it's physical, mental, spiritual, doesn't matter.
So the doctor tells me that she cannot breathe and she needs to be put on a ventilator.
Now how would I feel about that?
How would I react to that?
At that moment when she is there lying in bed, in that state, is there any other place in this world that I would rather be?
Of course not, right?
I would not leave my daughter's side even for a second.
I'd sit right next to her holding her hand because I love her so much.
So I'll constantly be by her bedside praying for her.
Now finally Allah answers my prayers and she wakes up.
And she wakes up, she looks at me and she says, You know Babu, I want ice cream.
Now, what do you think I'll do?
You want ice cream?
Of course.
What flavor do you want?
If I can't find it there, I'll drive anywhere I have to get that flavor of ice cream for her, right?
Isn't that what I would do?
Can you imagine how close I'm feeling to her right now at this point to see her wake up from that state?
What else do you want sweetheart?
Is there anything else I can do for you?
Is there anything else I can get for you?
You see?
And it so happened that right before she fell sick, we had a big fight.
She disobeyed me.
She was very rude to me.
She said some very harsh things and I was really angry with her when this whole thing happened.
Now she wakes up from that state and she remembers what she did and she says, Babu,
I'm sorry for what I did.
Please forgive me.
What do you think I'm gonna say?
Forgive you?
Sweetheart, there's nothing to forgive.
I'm not upset with you at all.
I don't care about the fight.
I don't care about what you said.
Don't even think about it, right?
Isn't this what we would do as parents?
Is there anything unnatural about what I'm saying?
Now, if this is how much we love our children, can you even imagine how Allah must love His creation?
According to Hadith, Allah holds the love of 70 mothers for every single one of His creation.
If in this kind of affliction I feel so close to my daughter,
When a creation of Allah goes through his trials and afflictions, can you imagine how close Allah is with him at that point?
Look how ready I was to respond to anything that my daughter asked for in that moment, instantly.
I am extremely limited by my capabilities.
But when a human being, a creation of Allah , when he is in pain,
and he asks for something from the depth of his heart whether it is for himself or for somebody else do you think Allah would refuse him in that moment?
because when we are in a state of affliction in that moment Allah is closest to us more than any other human being in that moment when we turn to Allah for forgiveness with true repentance there is nothing that He would not forgive
No matter what sin he or she may have committed, no matter how horribly that person might have behaved, Allah will forgive that instantly.
I mean, I do not hesitate for a second in forgiving my child regardless of what she did in that state.
Can you even imagine Allah's mercy?
The one who identifies himself with love, with Rahmah.
who holds the Rahma of 70 mothers in His heart for His creation do you think He would refuse to forgive?
If I was mad at my son and my daughter after waking up says to me Babu please forgive my brother do you think I would refuse?
Oh my God you are in such a difficult state you are in so much pain you are suffering right now
And even in this state you are concerned about your brother?
You want me to forgive him?
Absolutely.
Your request is granted.
Of course I forgive him.
I'll give you anything you want right now.
All you have to do is ask.
Tell me what else can I do for you?
Subhanallah, that is human state.
A parent's love for a child.
What would be the love of Allah for the creation?
So can you appreciate the beauty of this hadith now?
Why Rasulullah said that when you see somebody when you visit a sick person or somebody in affliction ask them to pray for you?
Because as I'm going through my affliction when I raise my hands and I ask Allah to fulfill the needs of another person or if I ask for my own forgiveness or if I ask for
You know, somebody else's forgiveness, there is no way Allah turns down my request.
Because I am extremely close to Allah in my moment of trial.
He is right by my bedside, holding my hand.
This is how His rashma manifests.
And this is why trials become the perfect opportunity for us to ask Allah for our needs.
Trials and afflictions could become one of the best experiences one can have you know an experience of awareness and the closeness of the love of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala May Allah grant us all the wisdom and the true perspectives of seeing Allah and his true intentions behind these acts of rewards and forgiveness and things like that so I hope
You know, this gave you a good perspective of how his Rahma manifests.
I mean, I just took two examples of friggin.
There are so many, but I just wanted to talk about the most important, the most common ones that we come across in our daily life.
So I hope this perspective helps us all in our efforts in moving towards him.
............